one of the one of the unique things
about this stretcher you guys is it's
kind of started with you guys playing
really good basketball in Las Vegas um
playing you know at a really high
intensity level and stuff like that and
then going through this sort of swoon um
what is your belief level about the
attainability of returning to what you
guys were in Vegas did you still feel
like that team exists within this two
just two games though it's just a small
sample everybody's getting so cracked up
about Vegas and keep bringing up Vegas
it was two games I mean we we took care
of that business that was an inseason
tournament we played we won it but that
was literally just two
games were the cracks were the the
problems that have presented themselves
over the last 13 games were they showing
do you think prior to that to the
stretch I don't know I don't really I
don't know I would have I'm not thinking
that far to in the past to be
honest I mean we just suck right
now and so as one of the leaders who's
done this for a while how do you try to
help this team get out of this rut what
what does LeBron James do what do I do I
show up the work punch my clock every
day stay positive and and go out and you
know try to lead out on the floor
Inspire on the floor you know that's
that's my that's what I
do